Frank Martin is the South Carolina head
basketball coach the Gamecocks have gone
to the sweet 16 now for the first time
in school history as they beat Marquette
maybe Duke and tomorrow night in new
york city they've got baylor coach
congratulations and happy birthday today
huh Thank You Danny
congratulations is that I made it to 51
or there were actually still playing
what's the bigger accomplishment
they're both unbelievably you had asked
me at 25 I take neither one but I'm
extremely happy but why did we were
thinking about this when the guys I said
you know we should get you on you know
once you guys made it to the sweet 16
and they go was he in the military now
they assumed you were a sergeant in the
military why is it that when people look
at you it almost you give that feeling
of you're gonna ask somebody to drop and
give you 20 I
it comes from my grandmother she her dad
my great-grandfather was the equivalent
of a lieutenant colonel that fought in
the independence war for Cuba against
Spain for Cuba's freedom back in the
late 1890s and obviously he raised her
and that's where that personality that
side of me that that's where it comes
from what kind of jobs have you had
besides basketball how long do we have
change boy at a pool hall dishwasher at
a restaurant busboy bartender waiter
landscaping newspaper back your member
of newspapers were relevant yeah yeah
they live at him yeah well I used to
know I actually go door-to-door
collection eruptions the one that
everyone likes talking about bouncing
I've had my share in teaching which is
my baby education what kind of bounce
there were you you know everyone thinks
bouncers there's some just like in
everything else
that let's start the fight let's throw
people around those moments aren't fun
that you learn to put out fires not
create fires it's uh though those
moments aren't a lot of fun so it's
you're always looking to settle people
down and kind of get the problem out of
the way not create a bigger problem
when's the last time you got punched in
the face oh it's been a while 90 middle
90s which is when I stopped that's not
fun what happened after that hurt he
didn't have a good needed that's not a
fun moment it's been a while don't know
why you got me thinking now it do your
kids know your players know what you
were like in another life I talked to
them about everything that my life's
been about because I think it's
important they understand that it's not
all glitz and glamour like everyone
thinks it is right now yeah that that's
the beauty of what I do do you're
looking for teaching moments yeah that's
and that's that's the beauty of what I
do then is I get these kids and and and
society's got them thinking that life's
easy and that it holds you back and I
show them like look at me man look where
I come from look look what I had you
know I I had people in my life that that
I could have strayed the wrong way but
instead they kept me in the right place
and no one ever would have thought that
I had a chance to ever be I was a bad
player talk about bad I was a bad player
but yet I'm the head basketball coach at
an unbelievable University and you know
and I just want I want people and
especially young kids to know you put
your mind to it you try to do right by
people you listen you don't run around
with the answers eventually a door opens
up be prepared to take advantage of it
you're pretty emotional after the win
over Duke yeah cuz you can't prepare for
the moment you hope for the moment but
why was the emotion so strong that I
don't even know if you could address
your team I don't know if you could talk
yeah I couldn't I you know it said I was
asked why'd you say let's go win this
thing
I couldn't get any other words out if I
would have tried to address anything to
the players
that moment I would have just completely
come apart at the seams
dan it's a lot of things you know it's
my family what you know the situation
that my family went through to come to
this country to raise me the players
that I've had in my life I've been
surrounded by incredible people my whole
life from other coaches to players you
know when I made I took a leap of faith
when I left Kansas State to go to South
Carolina I don't have a godfather but my
Godfather in this business you know well
Bob Huggins yeah so he's a he's a
godfather in a different way but I don't
I don't have anyone to protect me in
this business if I fail it's uh my
family my wife when I said let's do this
she didn't say well you know and then
she said this is what you think let's do
it my staff the players in that locker
room that we've stunk we were no good
we're no good not just as a team as a
program we were bad and and those kids
signed up and they came on board and all
of a sudden you know it all hit me when
I saw Coach K motion to his players
don't foul everyone thinks that you're
up seven with twenty seconds to go and
games over I'm over no I'm worried about
there's a seven-point play somewhere
that's gonna tie the game and and but
when I saw him waive his players off
that's when it hit me
I I kind of I kind of stood there and I
was like these kids actually got this
done this is unbelie--
correct and you're look at it Mike
sous-chefs key Kareem you've just beaten
his team and not yet and there's another
little twist to all that in 1998 I went
through a situation as a high school
coach where I lost my coaching job I
kept my teaching job but I lost my
coaching job so that's the first time in
my life that I said let me try and get
into college and I wrote 120 hundred 40
letters to coaches around the country
one guy sent me a handwritten note back
it was Coach K and I didn't even know
him back then he knew who I was because
I was part of a very successful high
school team but uh but all that kind of
all lumped into that one moment there
are school
we couldn't host an NC double-a event a
year and a half ago in our state now
we're able to do it we hadn't been to
the tournament in 13 years we hadn't won
a game in 44 years those kids didn't
have seniors to teach them how to become
seniors one day the my staff their
families they believed they all came
with me it's just there was a
culmination of all those things put
together you know it was for me
personally there's a powerful powerful
moment how how important was the game to
be in South Carolina because originally
it was gonna be in in North Carolina for
our state was incredible for her to be
able to show what a great state we have
how progressive we are how the the
willingness to continue to move forward
it was awesome and then for me you know
I'm trying to build basketball in our
state our state has some great high
school coaches you know that have done
it for a long time but never gotten the
recognition for it because our
university hasn't has postseason success
we fighting Frank McGuire dan fogler
Dave Odom unbelievable runner coaches
you know but we haven't had a postseason
success and so long that you know how
this goes you can be 29 and oh you lose
in the first round of the tournament you
had a bad year yeah and and because of
that moment that tournament in our state
we can grow basketball in our state it
makes it easier for us there's young
kids right now that want to be seen
there is don't want to be PJ Dozier
local kids that stayed stayed on board
and they're making unbelievable things
happen now I saw you a couple of years
ago at an Under Armor event but that's
not the first time we've met oh I'm just
gonna give you a hint
1997 San Antonio Final Four Bob Huggins
Billy Donovan Bret Baier up
car bombs I don't know I don't know this
day and age that last word I said is
kind of like but I think we all know
what we're talking about yeah we were
having a beverage or two there you go
yeah yeah yeah yeah boy coach was that
the last time you just had to escort
someone out of a bar if you know what I
mean I think we all needed to be
escorted out
you remember bret baier oh yeah he
played at Kentucky did you remember what
he did that night no I we were all
engaging in these adult activities and
drinking yeah and our conversations were
starting to kind of not only we can
understand the average person can
understand what we're saying anymore
yeah and he kind of disappeared he got
rid of a lot of those beverages through
the North End yeah
and came right back and did another bomb
wow did you go to the Kevin Costner
party though that year I'm okay that was
I want to say we were I can't remember
it was you know that little river area
and that's where we were at and I was I
was a young high school coach at the
time and hogs and I dear friends Billy
Donovan and I become very good friends
and they called me so were you I come
join us and you know and that was
awesome for me so I know you're a big
Reds fan and I grew up unbelievable Reds
fan and so it's our bombs
that's car bombs and you know that Irish
whiskey something else now if you make
the final four then let's do more car
bombs I you know then this what I'll say
I haven't had a drink in since the car
bombs don't know that that no I had
plenty here I got a great story for I'm
a pancreatitis so I'm in the hospital
for 14 days and it's the last day I'm in
the hospital and they're finally letting
me out this is in 2011 years ago and
hugs comes over we're in Manhattan
Kansas we had just taken the job
hugs comes to a hospital and says hey I
hear
you're good and you're getting out today
and I say he goes what are you depressed
about I said the doctor just said I
can't ever have cold beer again hug says
Frank let's be honest don't you think
you've had enough talk about the pot
calling the kettle black god I like that
Bob Huggins when he was at Cincinnati
had his own bar how about that all the
hugs and hugs him hugs in I was in it
when I was a high school coach in Miami
I was up there and we we had several
that night now I'm sure you did
Congrats on the success this year it's
great to see you and good luck against
Baylor tomorrow night coach appreciate
that Dan happy birthday
51 who would have thought I took the
under with you
approaches corner brought to you by a
Continental Tire Continental tires the
proud sponsor of the Dan Patrick show
the exclusive tire the Dan Patrick show
no matter where you drive or what you
drive Continental Tire they design a
tire for you and what you'd like to do
for more information visit Continental
Tire calm cut another tire for what you
do the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings
on audience